take the case of adoption you know we
know that there are cases where children
have to be adopted have to be removed
from their from their from their mothers
at Birth those are tragedies and they
cause emotional
harm to everyone involved long term and
they are in incredibly sort of closely
monitored by social services and are
seen as an act of Last Resort
what surrogacy does is it sets out from
the get-go to engineer that situation
for no good reason except for the fact
that the intended parents would like to
would like to have a child in that
fashion would prefer to do that than to
adopt or Foster or we like whatever
other options are available
I just think that the inconsistency
there
is really striking
um and it's because I don't think that
actually the surrogacy arrangement
really takes account of the child's best
interest at all I think it's actually
all to do with the desires of the intent